gotham's law-breaking taxi drivers the
overlooks reality bending layout and
alicia silverstone's hilariously genuine
mispronunciation keep watching for some
of the best movie mistakes that made it
into the final cut
a good soldier fights through peril and
injury and apparently so does a good
actor you've probably heard of a number
of performers who do their own stunts
but george mckay never expected one
particular scene from the 2019 war film
1917 to put him on that list while his
character's grueling sprint at the end
of the film was undoubtedly an intense
climax to his mission the actor wasn't
meant to take any hits as he ran across
the battlefield he had come out of
rehearsal for the scene unscathed but
there are no guarantees of timing in
such a complex scene on the actual day
of shooting as makai told jimmy fallon
he found himself taking multiple blows
from a slew of oncoming soldiers despite
never having rehearsed the shot that way
yeah well that's like that's a mistake
that made it in that wasn't meant to
happen
but an actor keeps going until the
director calls for a cut and for such an
important moment in the film he knew he
couldn't throw in the towel himself so
he kept moving and director sam mendes
never halted the take he must have
realized that despite deviating from
rehearsal something even more intense
was happening the shot that was never
meant to happen ended up being one of
the greatest triumphs of makai's
performance
while filming the princess bride carrie
elwes convinced christopher guest to hit
him on the head with the pommel of his
sword in a scene i swear it will be done
this action was scripted but the issue
arose because they apparently didn't
have a rubber prop sword to do the deed
harmlessly elwez thought it would turn
out fine if they just used a real one of
course he expected his co-star to give
him a gentle tap certainly not the level
of bludgeoning you'd rather have a
stuntman step in for but guests
apparently didn't know his own strength
it's part of the story for elwes's
character wesley to get ko so you might
never have known the actor had really
been knocked unconscious if not for an
interview elwes gave to sundance tv
describing the incident he said that the
next thing he knew he was waking up in
the hospital the blow actually ended up
creating a literal slapstick comedy
moment that made it into the film and
served its trademark zaniness incredibly
well
every job has its hazards if you work in
a kitchen you run the risk of slipping
on spills or burning yourself with hot
cooking oil if you work in an office you
might get carpal tunnel syndrome and if
you're channing tatum portraying olympic
wrestler mark schultz in bennett
miller's 2014 film fox catcher you might
break your hand pop your eardrum and cut
your head open all of these injuries
actually befell channing tatum during
the shooting of foxcatcher he broke his
hand while training for the role but you
can see the other two mishaps during the
film when mark ruffalo's character
roughs up tatums and clips him on the
air you see tatum wince his eardrum
actually popped in this moment and when
tatum slams his head into a mirror the
cut you see on his head in the film is
real the actor went a little too hard in
the moment and actually broke through
the wall behind the prop glass so when
you see the intensity of channing
tatum's physical reactions in foxcatcher
you're often seeing something all too
real perhaps his most telling line from
a variety interview on the subject
eardrums heal so i'm fine
sometimes you do the spit take and
sometimes the spit takes you or
something like that this mistake in the
martian is another case in which part of
the action was scripted but a mishap
actually elevated it to the next level
the martian is directed by ridley scott
a sci-fi legend who's apparently known
for getting scenes done in just a few
takes this is opposed to the dozens of
attempts that other directors might
often employ to get things just right
his films are said to be full of banana
peels because if someone accidentally
slips and messes up or eats it as donald
glover puts it the clumsiness just makes
it all the more real scott prefers this
humanizing element so he doesn't bother
doing the scene over just because
someone tripped and you'll often see
such unscripted stumbles in his films in
this particular instance a nervous
glover slips and falls on some spilled
coffee that he himself had spit out
earlier into a wastebasket he gets up
saying is fine and stays in character to
complete the scene the spitting out was
scripted but the slipping was not so
glover was quite surprised when after
the scene all ridley scott had to say
was that was great
actors like channing tatum and donald
glover didn't have to go to the hospital
for their injuries and slip ups but some
performers weren't as lucky brad pitt's
character in david fincher 7 actually
had to be changed to accommodate his arm
injury which he sustained during a chase
scene he accidentally put his arm
through a windshield after a scripted
fall from a fire escape the start even
required surgery for this wound from
that point on in the film pit's
character is always wearing a cast which
required fincher to alter many other
sequences in the movie to accommodate
the injury these scenes weren't just the
ones that in the film's chronology came
after the chase scene after all movies
don't always shoot their scenes in the
same order as they appear in the story
so there were a lot of scenes from
before the chase that hadn't been shot
yet and fincher had to hide pit's arm in
these moments to disguise the injury as
it hadn't happened yet in the world of
the story
in film just because something is
unscripted that doesn't mean that it's a
mistake some directors are pretty strict
about improvisation while others
encourage it on the actor's end some
improvised moments work much better than
others but even the ones that don't go
over well are typically conscious acting
choices not accidents in the case of
this sequence from captain america the
first avenger you could say it was an
improvisation and that'd be partly true
but it still definitely qualifies as a
mistake when you hear hayley atwell tell
it in what vanity fair describes as your
favorite scene in captain america
atwell's peggy carter sees chris evans
super soldier serum saturated steve
rogers with his shirt off for the first
time she reaches out in awe and
seemingly involuntarily touches his
chest but this wasn't only peggy's first
time seeing steve shirtless it was also
atwell's first time seeing evans
shirtless the actress said that she was
compelled to impulsively touch chris
evans chest and the director apparently
thought it was so organic that you can
see it in the film by her account it was
less of a choice in character and more
compulsion in the moment as herself
practically an accident but what a happy
accident it was atwell for her parts
claimed that it was the highlight of her
life
if you think that being in the
background of the film means you're
missing out on all the action that's not
necessarily the case sometimes you get
even more action than you bargained for
and it's not always a pleasant or star
making experience but you can rely on
the eagle-eyed film enthusiasts of
reddit to eventually get you the
recognition you deserve for taking a
background blow like a champ blink and
you'll miss it but when tom cruise
dismounts his horse in one scene in the
last samurai the steed kicks an extra in
the crotch you can tell from his
reaction that it wasn't some sort of
stunt but once you see it it's all the
more impressive that the extra remains
standing and though he stumbles a bit
takes it like a true warrior what's most
alarming is that no one around him
appears to flinch when it happens or
check to make sure that he's okay if you
want to believe the best you could read
the lack of response as evidence of the
stoicism of the soldiers either way the
injured soldier is a true champ
imagine your first chest waxing and your
first leading role in a film occurring
at the very same time it sounds like
it'd be a lot of pressure and that
things could potentially go really badly
that's exactly what happened to steve
carell his character in the 40 year old
virgin andy is trying to get into the
dating world for the first time and as
the title of the film suggests lose his
virginity he gets a lot of advice from
some pretty questionable but
well-meaning sources which ultimately
leads to him booking a waxing
appointment oh that sounds like it would
be nice
normally a scene like this would be done
with makeup and special effects but
corel thought it would be better if the
waxing was real he assumed it wouldn't
hurt that badly but you can tell in the
scene itself how shocked he is at his
miscalculation
the pain is real to make matters worse
the actor who played his waxer lied
about being experienced in the procedure
and apparently skipped an important
protective step that is applying
vaseline to his nipples poor steve the
master of physical comedy really went to
his limits this time and thankfully it's
not completely embarrassing rather it's
a hilarious and memorable scene and the
film wouldn't be the same without it
have you ever noticed that in many
scenes in the mcu movies tony stark is
munching on some sort of snack it's easy
to believe that it's just part of his
character he's quirky in many other ways
and always does whatever he wants so why
should the end of the world keep him
from snacking well apparently this habit
was never part of stark's character in
the beginning robert downey jr would
just hide snacks all over the set and
randomly start munching out during takes
without telling anyone he was going to
there was nothing anyone could do about
it since they never knew when it was
going to happen so the production just
made constantly eating and drinking a
comedic part of iron man's cavalier
character and honestly it fits just fine
is it a mistake it would have been for a
lesser actor as it likely would have
gotten them fired or at least heavily
reprimanded but rdj took his snacking
and made a meal out of it
a series of mistakes in titanic turned
out to be a blessing in disguise believe
it or not jack's now famous exclamation
at the tip of the ship wasn't originally
in the script in fact he and director
james cameron had tried a bunch of
different lines in its place and they
all fell flat time was running out and
the production was losing light but
finally after a bunch of mistake lines
an exasperated cameron told dicaprio to
just say i'm king of the world and
apparently dicaprio really didn't want
to at the time responding to cameron's
direction with an unconvinced what and
repeating the question when cameron
reiterated his instructions to the
second objection cameron simply replied
with quote just
sell it
we're eternally grateful that the
previous scripted attempts turned out to
be mistakes mistakes that in their wake
made room for one of the most
recognizable lines in one of cinema's
most revered films we'd love to know
what some of those failed lines were
though
when the futuristic bat vehicles
dominate the screen in the dark knight
trilogy most people really aren't paying
attention to much else but if you check
the traffic in the background there are
quite a few scenes in which gotham
citizens don't appear to be obeying
traffic rules these sequences usually
occur in high speed quickly cut chase
scenes so they're easy to miss and if
we're being honest a little nitpicky to
point out even if you do catch them
still the other drivers on the road as
the caped crusader rides his bat pod
after the joker are blatantly ignoring
street lights of course the taxi drivers
who nearly crash into the bat pod and
honk as he whizzes through them are most
likely stunt drivers given how close
they come to colliding with him not to
mention that these near encounters work
great to emphasize the peril of the
chase but if you look closely the lights
facing left and right where the vehicles
come from are red these collisions
should have never happened you could
nitpick and say it ruins the realism but
we disagree the whole premise of nolan's
trilogy is that gotham is a city of
debauchery mayhem and moral bankruptcy
there's often explicit debate as to
whether it can be saved we naturally
conceive of that in epic cinematic terms
grand scale sociopaths like the joker
corrupt officials at the highest levels
and sky high crime rates but if gotham
truly is a lawless city wouldn't that
extend to every area of life if people
aren't going to follow the law when it
comes to fraud murder and greed why
would they when it comes to traffic
many injuries are the result of talented
invested actors taking their scripted
scenes a little too far it's a testament
to their acting that they're willing to
risk a bodily injury in order to fully
inhabit a scene but we hope they don't
make a tradition out of needing stitches
in nightcrawler jake gyllenhaal plays a
freelance photojournalist named blue who
enters the competitive business of
covering violent incidents like crashes
and crimes and selling the footage to
news stations naturally he develops an
unsettling obsession with his work and
uses increasingly questionable means to
obtain the most compelling footage
before any of his competitors this means
going so far as to tamper with crime
scenes and manipulate police journalists
and criminals it goes without saying
that the guy is intense at one point he
punches a mirror which was part of the
script jake gyllenhaal needing stitches
in his hand afterward though that was
not part of the plan even still it all
fits incredibly well with a seedy
character who will go to any lengths to
get what he wants
you might have been told as a kid that
sugar can make your teeth fall out but
for one young extra in willy wonka and
the chocolate factory this threat became
all too real in an unexpected way when
confectionary magnate willy wonka
announces his golden ticket sweepstakes
it inspires a frenzy as people
everywhere flock to candy stores in
hopes of finding a ticket in one scene a
crown of children climber at the counter
of a sweet shop the proprietor while
singing the now famous the candyman tune
graciously invites the children behind
the counter to select their treats but
if you watch closely he almost knocks
one little girl's teeth out this moment
hasn't been spoken about in interviews
likely in part because the film vastly
predated internet discourse on such
subjects but it's a very small chance
the sequence was scripted or directed
this way you can see from the clip that
the little girl actually gets clocked by
the fold up counter it's pretty safe to
assume that they didn't plan for this
and then bring a six-year-old stunt girl
on set to get nailed in the face what
makes this goof so perfect though is how
the little girl doesn't seem fazed at
all she still rushes past the counter to
get at the candy it makes her seem so
hilariously invested in the treats that
she doesn't notice getting hit on the
chin and she won't be the last child in
the film whose dogged pursuit of sweets
gets her into trouble
while it's also full of all the sweetest
things in life willy wonka and the
chocolate factory has more than one
mistake hidden under the wrapper and one
continuity error in this film
accidentally makes a pretty powerful
statement when the malnourished charlie
eats what's probably his first ever
wonka bar we see him take a bite in one
shot while his mouth is already stuffed
but in the next shot just a couple of
seconds later his mouth is totally empty
you can't swallow almost an entire
chocolate bar in a matter of seconds it
definitely can't be done without making
a mess or at least needing to catch
one's breath afterwards at first glance
this is an extremely minor continuity
error and again since this is a viewer
caught slip up in an old film it hasn't
been addressed as a mistake by anyone
connected with the future we're just
deferring to the laws of physics here
but on that note this mistake can
totally be spun is the whimsical film's
magical realist take on just how
ravenous charlie is for the first ever
taste of wonka chocolate in his
impoverished life
the layout of the overlook hotel in the
shining stanley kubrick's film
adaptation of stephen king's disquieting
horror novel is spatially impossible if
you try to match what you see inside the
hotel with what you see on the exterior
there's simply no way to make it work
but when you think about the story
itself everything about the sinister
seemingly sentient hotel defies logic
and is meant to confuse the viewer and
occupants and drive them slowly mad so
why not the architecture itself some
people staunchly argue that the shining
set features many impossibilities from
windows that shouldn't exist doors that
lead nowhere to entire rooms that
couldn't possibly fit inside the hotel
others however say it's all part of
kubrick's genius and that the hotel
itself is clearly a supernatural
disorienting force an illusion in and of
itself in many ways it would certainly
lend new and unsettling meaning to the
now famous sequences of dany riding his
tricycle through the byzantine twists
and turns of the hotel's hallways he may
be wheeling in and out of reality
self-absorbed share living up to the
title of the film clueless mispronounces
words throughout the movie but what you
might not know is that actress alicia
silverstone herself is making these
errors whenever you hear her articulate
a word slightly wrong there's a good
chance that the mistake is genuine
apparently after silverstone had made a
few mistakes in the debate scene members
of the clueless cast and crew attempted
to help her out by correcting her
however director amy heckerling called
for everyone to stand down she felt that
mispronouncing haitians as haitians is
something cher's ditzy and self-absorbed
character would totally do so if the
government could just get to the kitchen
rearrange some things we could certainly
party with the haitians
and she was absolutely right cher's
mispronunciation serve as foreshadowing
for the growth she will experience over
the course of the movie that is from the
selfish ignorant girl she once was to
the conscientious caring person she
always had the potential to be and these
competing elements wouldn't have been
expressed as well without those
delightful mispronunciations
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you